the first thing we have to do is
actually test whether or not the
boundaries of this tile intersect with
the boundaries of the view rectangle now
if you look online you can actually find
some really nice blocks of code that are
2d rectangle to 2d rectangle testing
effectively we're applying the same
principle here we compute the boundaries
of the x and y of the actual tile and
world space and test this against our
view rectangle boundaries as well if the
tile lands outside of the view rect or
it's not intersecting with the viewrect
then it's not visible and we continue on
for those tiles that pass this test we
actually modify the world X and world y
translating it by the inverse of the
viewrect offset what this is going to do
is this gonna take our view rect and
actually recenter it on the canvas
itself so that the world X and worldwide
coordinates are actually canvas oriented
rather than world oriented these values
are then passed down to canvas draw
image directly and the image will
magically appear on the screen